Khloe Kardashian and Kylie Jenner are
ready to become mamas it's such a
beautiful thing
I can't wait to be a mom the pregnant
sisters are gearing up to welcome their
first kids this year a source tells ET
Chloe is focused on maintaining a
healthy pregnancy explaining her
priorities are working out eating clean
and promoting her show revenge body I am
staying so active right now so as long
as I can I want to keep that up also in
the works a possible trade deal for
Khloe's beau Cleveland Cavaliers star
Tristan Thompson the source says that
Tristan may move to Los Angeles and play
for the Clippers but regardless quote
Tristan is going to be 100% hands-on I
am really really excited about my future
just me interesting like we're doing so
well and I'm looking forward to see
where all that goes as for Kylie the 20
year old cosmetics mogul is enjoying her
time away from the spotlight the source
explained she too is focused on her
pregnancy and busy planning her next
professional steps woat Kylie's worked
hard her entire life and being a mother
will be a lot of work so now is a chance
for her to recharge I'm having so much
fun is I'm excited about it
[Music]